the Bethlehem municipality has
inaugurated a memorial for Serena the
veteran Al Jazeera journalist who was
killed by Israeli forces in May 2022
leader Ibrahim reports from Bethlehem in
the occupied West Bank
it's been almost 500 Days since an
Israeli sniper shot and killed Al
Jazeera Shirin but no one has been held
accountable yet while Palestinians
continue to fight for justice there are
still solidifying her memory and
remembering Shireen this is the latest
Memorial designed by the Bethlehem
municipality and the architect says that
he wanted it to resemble the symbolism
of Shireen the black slate showing
shireen's picture basically resembling
her absence from the screen it has also
assembled stones from different areas
from Palestine to show Jerusalem he says
that this is kind of the front and
center of shireen's coverage here in the
occupied West Bank and underneath it
there's a sentence that chirin used to
love
some absence there is greater presence
Shireen will never be absent we grew up
to her reports it's very difficult to
forget Shireen no Memorial no activity
is enough to honor her
difficult to see shireen's pictures and
memorials in different places in
Palestine and elsewhere in the world but
people here tell us that the most
important place she stays in is in
people's hearts and Minds Ibrahim
al-jazeera Bethlehem the occupied